Hello Freak bitches.
My kids are getting old enough now
where their sports leagues no longer,
you know,
for awhile there I was just driving me
crazy as it was apparent and go into a
game and realizing that they weren't
keeping score because they didn't want to
upset.
Oh my God.
That's the whole reason
why people get better.
You fucks.
Meanwhile the kids are keeping score.
The kids know for sure.
And kids don't want you to
blow smoke up their ass.
Right.
You don't want it.
They'd come off the court and if my,
you know what,
I would like the,
the oldest boy,
a scooter,
he's 10 years old and he's,
he plays a lot of Lacrosse.
He's been playing for
five years and so he's,
he really likes it and he does.
He does well,
but you know,
I'm not raising the
Division One champion there.
Right.
But he plays other sports too.
So there's,
there's sort of a well-roundedness there.
But we came off the field one day
and we were walking along and,
and um,
you know,
all the parents were kind of
marching off and the game was over.
And he says,
he says,
how do I do?
And I said,
well,
you know,
you could've done better.
Um,
I said,
I just get the impression he
didn't try as hard as you could.
What do you think?
And he looked at me irritated,
right?
He looked at me like,
I can't believe you didn't
just say I did great.
And so he said,
what?
And I,
and I looked at him,
I'm walking along and I didn't realize
the parents were within earshot.
And I said,
well,
look,
you know,
screwed.
Do you want me to blow smoke up your
ass or do you want me to be honest with
you?
And to his credit,
he said you,
and he'd be honest with me,
even though he wasn't happy about it.
The honesty.
So you should be honest with me.
And so we,
we tell kids,
we,
they know better.
You know,
if you tell a kid that they're great
and they're doing wonderful and they
didn't,
what did they take away from that?
They take away from it that
you're kind of bullshit,
right?
You know,
unless they're just super,
super young,
they pretty,
they get it at a pretty early age.
Well,
here's,
here's something that's important to
relate to children that you are not your
accomplishments.
You are you,
and the only way you are going to get
better at accomplishing things is to be a
hundred percent honest about the amount
of effort you put in and what the actual
result of that effort is.
Whether it's a failure or a
success that does not define you.
The defines your participation
in this particular activity.
It is not you.
You are an individual that will hopefully
learn from all of your endeavors,
but you're never going to learn
shit if you lie to yourself.
He never going to learn shit.
If somebody makes this,
nobody scores a point in there are new
winners and there are no losers in.
Everybody's amazing that that's not
good because good voice by the way,
it's not good because there's going to
be people out there that are fucking
driven and psychotic and
they're going to get ahead.
There's people that are task oriented and
goal oriented it and they have an idea
ahead of them going to try to
figure out how to make this happen.
They have a goal,
they want to reach it,
and if you're competing with that person
and any form of life and they're not
burdened down by the bullshit
that we give so many kids today,
they're going to have a massive advantage
and this idea that this kid who's been
coddled and treated like he's
always going to be a winner,
that somehow or another they're
going to be happier fucking crazy
kid camp process.
What's true and what's not and
the kid can't process criticism,
constructive criticism,
right?
You don't just stand there and
berate you're kid of course.
Now that's just as bad as the other.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
They're the guys that stand
on and everybody's seen them.
Right.
The dads and sometimes the moms,
it's down on the sideline and break
their kid because kids jeopardizing his
scholarship to some more on school morons.
But no,
I,
I think you're absolutely right.
They've got to,
the sooner they're able to assess that,
that equation effort,
uh,
and result and compare it to
what's going on around them.
Well,
look,
you know,
not everybody wins the lottery
of life to a little bit.
Isn't that the problem with socialism
and the idea of we should even out the
playing field?
Yes.
I mean the idea that competition,
you're a competition guy,
right?
But you know,
a famous Democrat,
John Kennedy said that life is
unfair and in a different era,
but it's not fair.
Right?
I mean,
just trying to bang a lot
of checks and you can't,
you know,
you can't dwell on the
things that you don't have.
Hey,
I wish I could've been
born better looking.
I could have been born taller.
You know,
you've got to make the most,
it's like playing poker.
You got to play it.
You could have the worst
hand and you can win the pot.
Right?
So,
you know,
obviously is it easier to win
the hand if you got right?
If you're a bad player,
you'll win nothing cause
everybody's going to drop.
Right?
And so even getting the best hand,
it doesn't necessarily mean you're gonna,
you're gonna you're
going to play it right.
But you know it's not,
I mean if two people,
if I want to hire somebody and the way
they look I believe is going to help me
earn more money because I think that
having a more attractive person in
particular business position is going
to somehow lead to greater sales.
I mean that's really the only reason
that you're going to pay somebody more
money if they look good.
Like look it on,
you know,
I go on Fox television or CNBC,
it's not an accident that all these
women interviewing me are pretty hot,
right?
I mean unattractive women could read the
news and ask me questions just as good
as they can,
but they're hoping and they're betting
that more guys like us are going to tune
in to watch a hot chick interview me.
Then a home we won and
they're probably right.
Right.
Because probably lots of the girls
that are applying for these jobs,
they're not getting hired.
No,
I agree with you 100% but there,
there's a fascinating thing that's going
on today where competition is thought
to be and somehow some way,
shape or form a negative thing.
And that this kind of competition,
whether it's even capitalism
itself is criticized,
right?
Like there's a lot of people today that
are in favor of socialism and it's one
of the reasons why Bernie Sanders
was so attractive is because like,
Hey,
you people that are not winning this crazy
competition out there that don't have
any desire.
We're going to even out this playing
field and those people that are out there
kicking ass and taking names,
we're going to take some of that money
and we're going to just give it to
everybody else.
Yeah.
That is the appeal of socialism
because it appeals to the lowest common
denominator.
That'll just appeal to ignorance.
But it appeals to greed
because an envy like,
oh,
this person has so much more
than me and it's not fair.
But here's the beauty of competition
because this is why we want competition.
We all want stuff,
right?
And,
and so I want people
competing to sell me stuff,
right?
I want to have as much as I
can as far as consumer goods.
That's what we all want.
We want products and services
that enhance our lives.
And the way we get the best products,
wait with the highest quality that deliver
the most value at the lowest price is
to have lots of competition.
All kinds of people
competing for my business.
Hey,
I've got some money to spend.
Oh,
buy my product,
buy my product.
Competition is what's made is what makes
sure that I get the best thing that is
soup
per hard to wrap your head around.
Yeah.
And then there's the big question,
right?
We wouldn't get paid the
big bucks if it were,
the big question is why?
Like why do you think
this is all happening?
Or do you ever use that word?
Why is,
why is a weird word,
right?
Yeah.
Why is it weird is happening?
It is,
uh,
what's causing it to happen?
What are the forces that
caused it to happen ever?
Why do you ever look at it all and go,
is there a purpose to all this?
So,
sure.
Um,
and I think the answer is no.
I think,
I think that,
yeah,
there's no reason why.
And again,
just looking up into the sky,
uh,
you know,
unless the purpose was
to make it pretty sky,
boy,
anything that we're seeing here on earth
could have been done much with much
less effort than making
100 billion galaxies.
Right?
Um,
there's no evidence than anything that
we've learned about science or the
universe that gives us a reason to believe
that there's a purpose behind it all.
Um,
if anything,
as time goes on,
the entropy of the universe is increasing
and the university becoming more
random and disorderly.
Um,
I think that we're,
you know,
riding a wave of a universe that is
growing and expanding and cooling and
becoming more and more disorderly.
And that's a finite amount of time.
So 14 billion years from the big
bang to today sounds like a lot.
That's 1.4 times 10 to the 10 years.
But the future of the universe
is enormously longer than that.
According to our best current theories.
It's it's way.
It's potentially infinitely long.
Anyway.
The last star is not going to burn out
until a quadrillion years from now.
We are very close to the beginning
of the history of the universe and,
but it's not forever.
It doesn't last an
infinite amount of time.
So the universe is a femoral.
We human beings and living creatures
are temporary structures within it.
And the idea that it's all
for some big cosmic purpose,
it seems to hold very little water.
Do you ever contemplate what,
what function human beings have in the,
in the university,
the way we interface with reality,
the way we interface with our,
the nature around us?
Yeah.
I think that a,
we don't have the function.
I don't think that's the right way
to think about what human beings are.
We should be glad to be alive,
enjoy it while we're here,
uh,
nice to each other and try to
learn more about the universe.
But it's not if we choose not to do that,
that's not going against any
preordained function that we have.
Your,
your own remarkably calm when
you discuss these things.
Like,
do you,
do you have any existential angst?
Do you have any,
like,
I think it's the other way around,
and honestly,
this is very,
very small amounts of data.
But,
uh,
from what I can tell when personal
tragedies strike people who were atheistic
cosmologists and scientists deal with
it way better than people who think that
we're embedded in a matrix with a
bigger purpose or a spiritual reality.
Really.
Yeah.
Cause you get that this is,
this happened and you to
have an infinite perspective.
Good.
Like when someone dies,
it's sad.
You can be sad,
but you see,
you can't say,
well,
it shouldn't have happened.
Right,
right.
This is,
these are the kinds of things that happen.
Okay.